[Music]
you want a podcast
i got a smart cat you want a podcast i
got a smart cat
you want a podcast i got a smart cat you
wanna you wanna if you wanna
you
[Music]
kevin smith
[Music]
welcome this podcast i'm kevin smith all
right we are still
in conversation with the boys of tesney
man with me again
as they were last week on smodcast as i
was with them last week
or last week on their testy podcast and
also on their patreon
we're back to finish our conversation
and i swear to you it finishes with this
episode and stuff
uh here on smodcast and on my youtube
channel where you're watching this i'm
sure a lot of people like holy [ __ ] i've
never
we never shoot smodcast so like this is
huge it's a big bonus for for my people
i'm sure
your people are used to seeing you
because you guys shoot your patreon all
the time and you shoot little sketches
and [ __ ] movies and make records and
[ __ ]
so much to talk about kids we've known
each other for so long and stuff and
even though we've known each other for
so long
and even though as i was saying later on
the podcast you'll hear it and i don't
get to complete that thought but since
we're doing the beginning of the podcast
now
i can close i can close i can bend time
and close the circle
and now i've spent so much time talking
it up i forget what i was gonna [ __ ]
say
goddammit what was it what was i just
talking about hour three is me going
wait a second what the [ __ ] was i just
talking about which is gonna be really
ironic for the rest of this conversation
may have just won his argument in
advance ladies and gentlemen should quit
while i was ahead
in any event the third hour of our
conversation uh
begins now so when the show dies
the first concern is not walter because
walter still has a job at the stash and
you know it didn't pay nearly as much as
the [ __ ] comic book men paid but
still there was something the big
concern was [ __ ] brian because brian
lived hand-to-mouth yeah and and
was very much so in the early years
there was there was the drug thing so
that
[ __ ] heard it as well but he he
basically made his money spends his
money and then waited
for comic book men to start again well
eventually the jugs went away
but he lived the grasshopper ant which
is so weird because the tesni fans are
ants and you're such a grasshopper
where you'd fiddle all day long until
the winter came
and you were like what the [ __ ] it's so
cold
[Laughter]
so there was that that was the first uh
i think it was jordan who raised that
concern jordan was just like well
brian is now penniless and i was like
what do you mean brian's got all that
i said i literally said brian's got all
that comic book men money and she goes
brian spends all his comic book money
and i was like i guess that's probably
right because he doesn't really have
another job like walter always had
another job when comic book men left
town
he was at the stash and he's responsible
yeah
you're the other guy who's just like
comic book man's gone and i'm gonna take
eight months off
which was which i utterly respected i
was like that is so true and on brand
and perfect for brian but so
when it ended jordan was just like brian
is
penniless and i'm like that's that's not
i wasn't like that's impossible because
i knew
that you didn't have an other gig and
[ __ ] but i was like no really
and so uh i don't know if i spoke to you
well i had to speak to you about the
cancellation of the show
so i think it was there that i was like
what are you going to do because jordan
was the first one that introduced the
notion of money
and so when i spoke to you and i was
like the show's canceled and [ __ ] i was
like what are you going to do about
a job and you're like i don't [ __ ]
know and this it thrilled me and made me
laugh so hard because you run
you know maybe they're still hiring at
the hazel movie theater i was like brian
you've been on [ __ ] television you
can't go back to being a manager
at a [ __ ] movie theater although that
would have been kind of hot you know
people coming in and they're tearing
tickets and they're like
i'm in the entertainment industry still
ah
that would be a good line uh or it would
have been this the sad remember when
jason was like [ __ ] delivering pizza
after mall rats and people like weren't
you in a movie and he's like yeah
five bucks he still talks about it it's
still haunts him he like you know he's
that's he's long past that but he still
carries that leg across
so um once it was once
you know i i'm certainly not responsible
for brian's well-being but like i had
fattened up this calf with seven seasons
of a tv show by being like there's
always
free money to be yourself brian and then
one day somebody pulled them it's never
gonna rain again right
yeah no brian you're [ __ ] so
the the patreon people have been uh
working with
jordan who runs our company and trying
to do a kevin smith patreon and i was
just like
what was then just simply called a
paywall and paywall always turned me off
as a concept because i'm like
well i started this [ __ ] free giving out
free podcasts i can't [ __ ] suddenly
start charging people how we make our
money was my old philosophy
is from the live shows it's very much
like [ __ ] uh
uh i don't want to call it ij
impractical jokers
um in their relationship with like the
commercial the show is a commercial
the live show is the filthy [ __ ]
lucrative so same thing with the podcast
for me historically the podcast had
always
been you know we do ads but the ads
really just cover the [ __ ] storage of
the podcast nobody gets rich off the ads
um where the money was was they listen
to the show for free and when we're in
town
they come [ __ ] see the show and pay
us to see a live show and we get to keep
that money and stuff
um when they were like when jordan was
like you should do this this is smart
and she's like the smartest person in
our world and stuff
so i was like yeah i get it and like
marc maron had went behind a paywall and
a few podcasters had ducked beyond the
paywall
but i was still trying to hold out for
like you know it's free and funny that's
our slogan and [ __ ] i can't like do
it like that and stuff and
and so she'd been riding me for like
four months and like kind of
built quasi versions of what it could be
and always present to them like this is
what it could be and i'm like
it's still there's a price tag i can't
do it this is what it could be this is
price tag i can't do it and she's like
well that's the point of the patreon
it's like
these people can support your art and
i'm like i get support from my
[ __ ] art elsewhere and stuff blah
blah blah so this went on for a few
years
then all of a sudden this happens and i
was like hey man
why don't you do the patreon thing with
[ __ ] testy
i was like because they got an audience
that buys [ __ ] they had everything to do
with those two albums
because i remember looking at those two
albums and being like
the [ __ ] boss of these kids they made
[ __ ] records
which means somebody bought those
records because if i know flanagan
he buying a bunch and letting them sit
well yeah he but
it was the idea was his idea remember to
tell me and i was like no way we're not
doing albums
and the moment you saw it worked you're
like move quinn we're in the album
business now
podcast too right we're going to roast
you but it was seeing that it was seeing
the records and realizing and like in
conversation
after conversation with jordan because
she was always dialed into what you guys
were doing and stuff
and she was like their audience like
pays for things like they
you know she's like your audience pays
to see you when you're live but like
their audience is like
more ardent more hardcore than your
audience
like in a way it's it's tighter i i.e
another word is smaller but like that
sounds dismissive but it's a
tighter group but it falls into that
direct philosophy
of if you can find a thousand people to
pay you one you know every month to do
whatever it is you do quit your job
because that is your [ __ ] career
so at that point i was like you know i
this ain't for me
although it is now we have that kevin
smith club and we
there's a paywall world that i'm in as
well um
but back when it started i was like the
same for me i was like but
this might be [ __ ] perfect for like
testy and stuff like that
that also well that came directly from a
stoner
himself who was stoned when he said it
but then the person who built it with
you guys who walked you into patreon and
said
[ __ ] up is a massive [ __ ] stoner
herself so in that long conversation i
was like well i
i hate to trace every nickel back to
stoning but like marijuana i said your
money is marinated in marijuana it's
dirty money because that three-hour
conversation
two hours of it was you being like i can
talk about
spider-man or six million dollar man
because i was high and i'm like kev
i know you we you would talk about those
things and you would still see
all the things you did if you weren't
stoned yes so i
i wasn't but to be fair i wasn't like
that's the only reason i did it that's
true
because one of this and this was the
part that was like
this this to me was adorable and
heartbreaking at the same time walters
walter like was talking about me being
an addict and i was like what are you
[ __ ] talking about because i don't
for the record anybody who doesn't
realize i obviously don't
subscribe to the theory that [ __ ]
weed is a drug it's [ __ ] very tame
and [ __ ] like that and it's not the 80s
anymore so i don't think like this is a
hardcore [ __ ] drug
but my at one point he was like um
when we were doing comic book men you
couldn't [ __ ] come upstairs and
record before you had you had to go
downstairs and smoke weed in order to
come up to the table and [ __ ] have a
conversation
and i was like oh my god walt if you
would ever just walk downstairs you
would have seen that was not the case i
was like
literally i put on my makeup and i
blazed a joint every [ __ ] time
but it wasn't like if i don't do this i
can't do that it was like
this is amazing this is going to take it
to [ __ ] paradise
because as i explained to walter i was
like with comic book men i was able to
close
circles in time i was able to loop time
back so the notion of
could you imagine if we got to sit
around how did that talk to each other
that just sounds like it's not a dragon
stoner talk though for sure definitely
stoner
but i was like can you imagine could you
imagine yes
spidey went cosmic i could go cosmic too
we're all cosmic we eventually all go
back into the cosmos my friend we're all
just energy that goes back out so you'll
be there as well
too yes and based on the curve we're on
your learning curve you'll pick that up
in 20 years
what that like you'll sound like me in
20 years you'll be like you know what
kev was right i am cosmic
by doing what i'm not saying wheat for
sure
he has said that spices are a drug
that was that was the one part of our
conversation that i was glad i was not
way privy to is how like i remember you
being against him like doing pills and
[ __ ] and i was in
that with you so i was like you know
[ __ ] yeah that's bad but he's against
me
not me i was giving you money
and that's a good threat right there
like i didn't know that you went at him
about like weed and [ __ ] like that
because i would have been like weed what
like that's oh my god let him have his
weeds i don't know i i saw
a different i mean it could have been
other things but you know that were
causing a different brain
a different side of brian it may
probably was
but oh in his case it was [ __ ] pills
bro no no this was after pills
this was after pills when he was just a
weed of christmas or the christmas
it was the christmas before and uh it's
more about mental instability yeah
i think it's probably yeah probably but
i all i could see i was frustrated with
my friend because he was depressed
no no no no no he was he was does it
affect me
no that's my question i completely
understood his reaction afterwards
because we
we went out reaction to what i'm missing
a piece of not yet did you have a fight
or something
no no no we went out to get something to
eat well i'm talking about what spurred
it on
we went out to get something you're
talking about this right yeah it's all
one big ugly enchilada
[Laughter]
we went out to get something to eat and
i i had i was having a hard time with
frustration and problems like especially
at restaurants and [ __ ]
so when we got the [ __ ] and then you
throw water at some lady for their
table or something she put water on me
so i don't sew it on my bad my bad
uh but i i have a low tolerance so when
somebody takes a long time to get to the
table i'm like what the [ __ ] and you
know i'm like looking around but it's
like
i don't i don't it doesn't register what
i'm doing
it registers with other people so when
like he got mad and he was like i'm
never going out to eat with you ever
again
and at the time i was like why what the
[ __ ] but like after i got medicated and
[ __ ] it's like oh okay now i understand
like now i understand why he would be
like this is not something i want to be
around
because it's weird it's [ __ ] up give
me he's been around it too give me an
example
because i don't think i've ever seen it
i'm not saying dredge it up but what is
it like
like how different than you are you at
that time
uh i don't know i would say pretty
different
yeah pretty different and i guess just
like irrational anger in a moment
about something that's inconsequential
like like
ultimately i should like i was there
with uh get him and walt and sunday jeff
and we went out to eat from off camera
out of the boys
after having just delivered some money
to an orphanage because we did a
christmas thing we went into an
orphanage and gave him the money
and instead of just like being like wow
sitting down there like i've closed the
loop in the cosmos
[Laughter]
that's what i said i was like walter i
was spending time
like 50 000 times in that conversation
it was such a great notion
and he didn't react to it the first time
so i kept leaning in just like
did you hear me say i'm bending time
it's a comic book thing you should like
this
i gotta i gotta know i know you i just i
before we end this podcast i gotta know
what
happened when you hung up the call on
your end like like what is that like to
get yelled at by wolf flanagan
it wasn't yet but i'm trying to hear it
it was it was a three-hour call and the
first
hour was we were we were like battling
about something completely unrelated to
weed that then
brought up [ __ ] weed so once the weed
conversation started then we went
another two hours which i was happy that
it went longer with that conversation
than the previous conversation
but i was and i don't mean this in this
dismissive way you obviously know how
much i worship you and [ __ ] like that
but i was incredibly bemused because i
was like
i'm talking to somebody from the year
1982. like it sounded like somebody who
had just listened to nancy reagan sit on
mr t's lap and be like
don't do drugs kids and so the whole
time i was like
like doesn't he realize the whole
country is about to go legal like this
this [ __ ] is tame it's like tamer and
cigarettes you have to look at it from
my point of view i've seen
i've seen people that i knew before
they were doing this and didn't need
this and now it looks like they need it
bad like who
like me but do you feel like i need it
bad or do you feel i like that i want to
mention any names
well that's the difference so i said to
walter i was like cause walter was like
i was a bad friend and i should have
[ __ ] told you and [ __ ] i said walt
if i'm an addict to anything it's
[ __ ] food
and you never said [ __ ] to me when i was
a big fat [ __ ] and he was like that's
i'm not supposed to say [ __ ]
i said i'm not saying you should but i'm
saying you can't feel bad about telling
me
like you shouldn't smoke weed because
you never [ __ ] said why are you
eating like that you're gonna [ __ ]
die i said i wound up almost dying
from [ __ ] eating food and i called
walt like last week i had to take a week
off
of smoking weed because of i had
periodontal surgery
so for a week why why can't you smoke
weed they just they don't let you
i think it's the sucking action right
you can create an abscess through
sucking but you can also
heat your gums and and then they won't
heal and so can you do edibles
i could have but i don't really [ __ ]
with edibles don't do anything for me
because i
this this this this doesn't really help
my cause i usually have so much thc in
my system
that an edible won't really have an
effect on me
so there it is so i had so i'm off
smoking for like a week
and at one point i called him he's been
vindicated i know
i know as if like you're right i'm wrong
so i called him up and we were talking
about something and i was just like hey
man i just want you to know
i've been off weed for like four days
and what i really want
when i'm what i feel my addiction is is
sugar because even though i've had mouth
work like all i want are [ __ ] sweets
like i want to eat a cupcake so [ __ ]
badly
i said weed i'm not even thinking about
but the cupcake i [ __ ] want and stuff
so that that was weird because there's
no one in the world has ever been
physically addicted to wheat it's
impossible you can't get addicted i
i don't i don't subscribe to that you
don't have to but science tells us that
you literally cannot
physically be dependent it can be
political too though and there there
could be many
reasons what who who who's benefiting
from that stoner scientist
but they're apparently losing though
because the world is still run by
non-stoner scientists who don't
subscribe because everything's going to
be illegal
i hope so [ __ ] soon we've only have
12 states so far but no that's that's
legit science not crazy science it's
just you cannot physically it's not like
alcohol
which has a physical addictive component
or heroin which is definitely physically
addictive
i mean if you're if they throw you in a
jail cell
to dry out for the night um if you're
a drinker they will give you booze
because you could
[ __ ] go and you can have a heart
attack you could go into withdrawals
physical withdrawals that could kill you
heroin
they won't give you anything because you
can ride that [ __ ] out you're going
to be uncomfortable you're going to
throw up
they give you some oxygen sometimes well
but even if if they're if you're just in
like a drunk tank and they're like [ __ ]
you we're not giving you nothing
they won't they'll give a guy who's a
drunk a drink but they won't give a
junky drink and nobody [ __ ] gives
anything to stoners because there's no
physical dependence so if i was like
i haven't smoked weed in 24 hours what
about a mental dependency you know
well that's a great question do i have a
mental dependency
i don't think so because in the course
of a week i was never like where's my
[ __ ] weed like
it wasn't the first thing that occurred
to me the first thing that occurred to
me was comfort
comfort eating that is my biggest and
really in my
perspective my only addiction after i
stopped smoking cigarettes
and that was the other thing you never
like we're like you shouldn't smoke
cigarettes either
so it was cute that you were like don't
smoke weed it was like bambi coming out
it's kind of like foolish
any a man as smart as you yes knows you
shouldn't be smoking cigarettes
yeah you're right and i stopped but it
took me a while i said and to be fair
stupid that i started i started so late
in life it wasn't even a high school
thing
i started at the flood at the nor'easter
because i [ __ ]
stayed you know in highlands overnight
in my house it was underwater and [ __ ]
like that and then
in the morning i got up and i was like i
might as well go to quick stop because i
it's depressing being in [ __ ]
highlands because we were underwater so
i walked up the hill and [ __ ]
walked to quick stop because both of my
cars were flooded and when i got to
quick stop to open up the toppers didn't
come because they too were [ __ ]
trapped in manalapan or whatever the
[ __ ]
and there was a line of people in front
of a quick stop as soon as i opened the
door every one of them were cigarettes
and so like
by the end of that day i was like if
people will come out
in this [ __ ] holistic weather
cigarettes must be amazing
and i tried a winston and then uh then i
slowly started smoking i stopped smoking
and cigarettes carcinogens definitely
would have killed me my doctor told me
he was just like
you have the the you know the lad my led
was fully
uh occluded which means that's
cholesterol and [ __ ] like that so it's
all
little debbie swiss delights and [ __ ]
oatmeal pies crap food was in my
lad but my heart he said he's like oh i
can tell that you used to be a smoker
and i was like i used to be
i was like i smoke weeds because that
don't count i said why he goes because
it's about nicotine and carcinogens
and i was like and you could tell he's
like i could see that you used to he's
going but it's clearing up when was the
last time he spoke cigarette i was like
oh [ __ ] 10 years ago and stuff he's
good things like because if you've been
a cigarette smoker and this happened
i could not have saved you your heart
would have [ __ ] died and stuff
so and my doctor and i've said it in a
few places but my
my not my cardiologist but when i went
to see my gp after the heart attack and
[ __ ]
like after like a week after i was out
of the hospital and [ __ ]
um i i said look i didn't want to bring
this up with my cardiologist but i got a
different relationship with
with my gp and [ __ ] she's cool so i was
like i just need you to be honest with
me because i hadn't smoked wheat at that
point in over a week right because i was
like
maybe we'd created this heart attack i
didn't know i didn't think it was my
unhealthy living condition
in terms of what i ate i was like maybe
we did this so i asked the doctor i was
like before i had the heart attack that
night
smoked a massive [ __ ] cannon of a
joint i was like could that have
anything to do with it she goes no quite
the opposite probably saved your life i
was like what the [ __ ] do you mean she
was like
anybody told that they're having a heart
attack the first thing that happens is
your blood pressure
immediately [ __ ] triples and
compounds because you're like i'm dying
and people wind up dying because of that
they panic themselves into a worse
condition
she was like you were so blazed that
somebody told you you were about to die
and you were like wow man like um
well i guess i've had a good life and
things are sweet like i was real
introspective i wasn't like you gotta
[ __ ] save me i was just like well
like i'm 47 and that's younger than my
old man he died at 67 a heart attack i
said but like
i did cool [ __ ] and i had cool friends i
literally thought about the people
at this table everybody at this table
and on my on what i considered to be
my deathbed when i was told you have an
80 chance of dying tonight and only 20
chance of walking out so at that point i
was like all right
odds are i'm not leaving this [ __ ]
place so as i sat there while he was
like you know mind you i was on drugs
but the drugs they gave me they put me
on fentanyl i didn't even know i was on
drugs after the words i came out of the
room
and jennifer was like oh my god how are
you i was like i'm fine she goes you
must be really high i was like they
didn't give me nothing i did that whole
thing so
the guy was like he's on fentanyl right
now like up to here so
i was on fentanyl so i guess there's a
drug component there involved and stuff
but they keep you in twilight they don't
put you out so you're
i was able to talk to him the whole time
and and like i'm sure that irritated
and [ __ ] because i was like literally
narrating the
the end of what i considered to be the
end of my life and it wasn't weepy it
wasn't like why
it wasn't schindler's list where i was
like one more pin this would have saved
a life
i was like completely and totally
satisfied
like i was like i i it was better than i
ever expected and better than i deserved
and better than i was gonna be giving at
birth and
everything was just like a [ __ ]
joyous run of like we get to do this we
get to do this
and i was like yeah it ends [ __ ]
early and [ __ ] like that but
you had it so good don't be that [ __ ]
at the party that's like you know
[ __ ] you got any more beer like just
leave when it's time to go
like [ __ ] i had a good time push back
from the table and [ __ ] leave
accordingly and so i reached this place
because i did i l i'm no [ __ ] i was
going through
my life and not like my life flashed
before my eyes because there was no
movie
but i was sitting there going like at
any second
this is it eighty percent means that any
second
like i go and there's no warning bell
there's no him going like oh [ __ ] look
out it's like the widow maker is
it has nothing to do with the skills of
the surgeon it has nothing to do with
the health of
of the patient the lifestyle one's lived
it's like you either go or you [ __ ]
don't
and there's an 80 chance you go so the
whole time i'm like well this is it and
[ __ ] and i did get to think about my
whole life
and i thought about i can't think about
the adventure
and i always talk about my life at
beginning as if like it began with
clerks and stuff and of course i mean
professionally speaking
but it began before clerks with you guys
so as i sat on the table
one of the things that literally made me
at peace
with potentially rejoining the cosmic
was the fact that i was like
i literally said this i [ __ ] you're
not i was like i had such good
friends like
it made it okay to [ __ ] stare into
the face of the void and be like all
right
[ __ ] what more can you ask for and
then [ __ ] saved my life and
suddenly i was like what am i gonna do
for the rest of my life because i was
ready i wasn't even like i wanna die but
i was at such utter peace
in a way that like you know everyone's
scared to death and [ __ ]
you know i don't care who you are
somebody's like i don't [ __ ] fear
death nobody wants to die because nobody
knows it's on the [ __ ] other side
and i least of all didn't want to die
because i have a good [ __ ] life like
i don't want to stop being kevin smith
it's [ __ ] rocked and [ __ ]
but faced with the notion that it was
going to happen one of the things that
made me go like you know what
i can do this was the people at this
table
um that i would never come to that
conclusion
if i wasn't a stoner i wouldn't do that
kind of thing
like you know i told walter at one point
too i was like well if i wasn't a stoner
we wouldn't even be friends anymore like
like
when people get into my line of work and
they get competitive
and they start cutting everyone out of
their [ __ ] lives and i held on to my
friends that was a big part of my shtick
as we all know and stuff and involved
them all
but then there came a point in my life
where [ __ ] [ __ ] the bottom fell out
and that was when like you know post cop
out and [ __ ] where i was like oh
nobody's
into these antics anymore or anything
like that
um in that time
i had to come to grips with the fact
that like it'll never be like it was
but it could potentially be something
else if i
did if i wasn't a stoner i probably
would have been like
i gotta well [ __ ] that movie lost money
i gotta [ __ ] make a movie that makes
money and [ __ ] i gotta get on that track
where you make a [ __ ] movie that
makes money and
i gotta get one and desperation breeds
contempt and and
failure as well so i'm i'm not tom brady
where the whole world's going you
[ __ ] suck you know like watch me win
the super bowl and [ __ ]
i don't have those skills i've never as
much as i love gretzky
i never identified with the skill level
of a gretzky
what i identified with is the humanity
of the [ __ ] gretzky i think that's
the thing that i was most drawn to
so the notion of like you know
i have to look out for number one and
make sure that this career keeps going
i would have [ __ ] let everybody go
like if i wasn't a stoner
i would have [ __ ] threw everyone over
the [ __ ] boat
to save me and myself and because i'm a
stoner
you can see every [ __ ] connection
and you can you can what is it called a
gun
uh pending time thank you you can bend
time i said it so many times i don't
even remember the phrase
you can bend time back to the essential
important
moments because that's all it comes down
to life comes down to
very important moments that shape the
rest of the moments
i think at one point before we
both go cosmic yes we're going to have a
conversation and you're going to realize
that you didn't need weed to do all that
if you could flip me that'd be amazing
i'm not going to flip you it's going to
be something else
but i don't think it's going to be me
what would it be who knows what it'll be
but i think you'll come to the
realization that like
that you you weren't a person that would
throw everybody overboard
to save your career because i can't see
how i don't know
i don't know but you guys never you guys
never saw trapped rat
kevin smith you guys seriously you guys
were out here
like blissfully [ __ ] living your
lives on the east coast and i was dying
a million deaths on the other side of
the country going like i'm irrelevant
nobody cares about me
[ __ ] i'm done the internet hates me i
had to deal with a lot of [ __ ] like
the world
turned on me at one point before cancel
culture began i got [ __ ] canceled
twice
once for [ __ ] too fat to fly and once
for like picking a fight with film
critics
which both of those i still [ __ ] reap
downside uh [ __ ] uh what's the
opposite of benefits
i still dislike abilities liabilities
there's still
yes there's still liabilities that come
out of those two
experiences like and and
so yeah i i was in a in a very bad place
rat if that trap
rat actually you know sunk
yeah it probably would have been um
a difficult period that would have
stretched on but eventually
kevin smith
kevin smith that you know that that i
became friends with yes
would have resurfaced not res not you
know
but would have realized that like i
don't need to throw anybody over the
board
to be to be perhaps but perhaps by then
it would have been too late and i would
have already thrown people overboard
possibly but i mean you would have
probably have uh
if all the people you threw overboard
you probably would have contacted
and made it right the [ __ ] back up on
that boat or
yeah but by the time i would have
contacted it would have been like
hey i'm 65 how you been it's been 10 or
15 [ __ ] years and stuff
and although it's not like all of us or
any of us talk well you guys talk
[ __ ] all the time but it's like not
like i see you or see you or see you on
a regular basis or we talk on a regular
basis and yet i still consider you
some of my closest [ __ ] friends in
the world so being that
if i had gotten to a place and this
hypothetical is going way down the road
where i did
like a trap rat throw everybody
overboard and [ __ ]
me coming back wouldn't have meant
anything because you guys would have
been like oh this [ __ ] guy of course
he comes back now or something like that
i don't think so but i mean that's that
that that being neither here nor there
the
in terms of what might have eventually
happened if i came back and stuff
but i can tell you i can tell you for a
fact
i know that's like that's what provides
[ __ ] fodder for the
for the podcast normally but i feel
i feel and since i'm in the
position to make the call i think my
take is a little more accurate on it
i feel like here
uh there'd be no patreon if i wasn't a
stoner not because i'm like i'm a stoner
that came up with the idea
i wouldn't have given a [ __ ] that he's
out of money and [ __ ] i would have been
like what the [ __ ] i just lost a tv show
i'm out of [ __ ] money
[ __ ] him everyone everyone fend for
themselves and [ __ ] but because i was a
stoner i was like
what's gonna happen to brian it's like
the first [ __ ] thing when somebody
brought up the notion of money but but
that's saying to
that's painting yourself an inaccurate
picture of the man that i became friends
with though who just cared about himself
though
before we before but think about it when
you knew me
this this version of kevin smith that
thankfully never came to be
would be the one that was so predicated
on i need to get back where i was
i need to be this guy that everyone
loved and was the golden boy
that i would have eventually cast
everything to the side to chase that
goal
i know people that do it i see it all
the time in my line of work man
people where it's no longer about like i
just want to tell a story
it's like i gotta get back on top i
gotta [ __ ] be i gotta make this if
i don't have a hit i don't [ __ ]
matter being a stoner really allowed me
to be like
it's all right that not everyone loves
me anymore because a lot of people still
do and i'll just work with them and for
them
and so it gave me perspective healthy
perspective
that i wouldn't have had if i didn't
have a haze of [ __ ]
smoke around me because i'd be [ __ ]
forced to deal with
these negative feelings anyway though
which conclusion
that it's okay if they don't if never
occurred to me before that you were the
first person that made me go like oh
[ __ ]
that's why i [ __ ] started hanging out
with unm because you're the first person
i ever met that didn't give a [ __ ]
about what other people thought and i
[ __ ] loved that i was like this guy
he don't give a [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] like he's got a mullet and
he [ __ ] reads comic books he's older
than me
i was like he don't have a [ __ ]
license and i do
and he does not give a [ __ ] like since i
didn't give a [ __ ] he did it [ __ ]
rightfully
you had like get him junior myself
driving you around new jersey
but then in addition to that there was a
guy who also didn't give a [ __ ] in a
completely different way
while he did give a [ __ ] on some ways
like what i recognized in brian was oh
my god
he's as embarrassed as being himself as
i am
but brian is much better at projecting
out on others
and distracting you from the fact that
he doesn't like himself and stuff
and so i always thought that was
incredibly charming and i don't he
doesn't put people
down to like make himself feel better
but brian
ask mike and mink yeah well yes that's
true
we do have a whole entire seven seasons
of a tv show
with brian doing exactly that but it was
both of your
like for lack of a better description
commitment
to being yourselves that means the story
you probably don't tell but i
used to tell it on stage like all the
time i was like i
i am so weak-willed and i so
don't know who i am even to this day
i'll be 51 in june i'm still [ __ ]
figuring it out
what i was attracted to about you and
you was you knew exactly who the [ __ ]
you were
and as i say on stage all the time i'm
like i
as somebody who didn't have that being
around that
gave me support like that was something
to aspire to like
these guys don't give a [ __ ] they really
don't give a [ __ ] and it's not like
they're losers and they don't give a
[ __ ] but it's like they just didn't give
a [ __ ] across the board
the comics thing was huge because i'm
like but no everyone [ __ ] makes fun
of adults that read comics
and he didn't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] and
you were just like
[ __ ] like you epitomized not giving a
[ __ ] but
deep down you did give a [ __ ] and that's
that's
if you were just like some person that
was like [ __ ] everything i don't think i
would have been
like if you were a nihilist i would have
been like brian's fun once in a while
but
like i don't like to go to dinner with
him because sometimes those
conversations
are pretty dark but at the heart that's
why randall is the way he
he is randall is the most cynical human
being in the world and my favorite
moment in anything i've ever made is
that moment in clerks 2
when he [ __ ] goes i buy the quick
stop and reopen it myself
because that's the guy who like plays it
like this forever
wearing his heart on his sleeve for like
the first time and so you don't do that
often i can't point to like a moment in
life obviously your marriage is one of
those moments
but i can't point to a moment in our
history where it's like brian [ __ ]
profoundly
like said or did this and [ __ ] but i
always knew that that was
at work in you like recognizes like and
i saw that in you i was like oh he
he feels as awkward about himself as i
feel about myself but the difference is
he's fast quick and clever and so
[ __ ] you'll never know how he feels
about himself and in fact he includes
himself in on the joke and puts himself
down at the same time that's what's
brilliant about it
so not only can he [ __ ] ratify his
false conceptions about himself by being
like i'm a [ __ ] loser too
but it also makes him bulletproof to
attack anybody else in the room because
it's like you can't attack men he's like
why he attacks himself
he literally just attacked himself so of
course he can go after the next guy
um that those those character traits
fashioned and built me i don't get to do
the things that i do
without that when you're like if you
didn't smoke weed you would have done
those things
[ __ ] i know that for a fact because
i know like i wouldn't have even gotten
as far as i did without weed
without [ __ ] people to be like yes
that is how i can be
yes that is how i can be um and that
gave me the [ __ ] fortitude to be like
maybe i could make a movie something i
was so terrified to say to both of you
because i was terrified that you'd be
like you know that's [ __ ] stupid and
it wouldn't have been stupid it would
have been the 90s or 80s equivalent for
that word
but but i would have been talked out of
it so easily because i'm like they're
[ __ ] right man if they think it's
stupid then [ __ ] why are we doing
this and i shouldn't be thinking about
this
so i kept it quiet as long as i could
until i was a week away from going to
film school and then i was like i'm
going to film school because i want to
make a movie i'm gonna come home we're
all gonna make a movie together
and the two of them looked at me as if i
was like i'm gonna slip under the table
and suck both of your dicks and you're
gonna have a
sword fight in my mouth whoever comes
first loves me the most and this had
this [ __ ] look like what are you what
are you talking about and [ __ ] and i had
to kind of
explain that like on the down low i've
been playing to film school
because i didn't want you to find out i
didn't want brian to find out that i
tried stand up one day which is in the
documentary which made me laugh so hard
in malcolm's doc at one point you're
like
hey later on years later he told me he
went and did stand up i'm glad i didn't
know i wouldn't approve
[Laughter]
but it was you know you you take
what's useful and you perhaps
overlook what's not and what was not
useful of course was two guys who were
like
don't do anything at the risk of looking
stupid because this was a person that
wanted to enter a field that's all about
look at me i'm stupid like you know
entertainment is essentially [ __ ]
that
so i took like my the
my key character traits or the things
that i would hang my new version of
myself on because
this version of kevin smith doesn't even
resemble the one that ernie went to high
school with
and this present version of kevin smith
probably
resembles a little more closely the
version of kevin smith kevin
smith 2.0 or whatever that [ __ ]
launched when we met and stuff like that
but it was the fortitude that i chose to
cling to i didn't cling to
the weakness of like he doesn't like
himself why would which always befuddled
me because i'm like
most fascinating [ __ ] man i've ever
met how does he not love himself like
the rest of the world how does he not
have the joy that he derives from others
people in his presence
just [ __ ] get happy and [ __ ] like
that and then it's like it's back to the
old like
polyachey sad clown thing like the guy
who goes the [ __ ] oh i'm so sad
doctor i'm so depressed and it's like
well
you should go see the great [ __ ]
poliaccia this amazing clown in town
you're like but doctor
i am polyachey um i left that behind and
and in your case i left some of the more
judges you should be on and i
and i focused on [ __ ] like the things
about you that i was like that's
who i want to be that's who i want to be
that's why i know that if you had ever
said
don't go to film school don't [ __ ]
smoke weed
i would have been like he's right i
shouldn't do these things i didn't do
any of those things
thank god absolutely but i i wasn't the
one that
brought it up you brought up when we had
that conversation where you were like i
[ __ ] should have told you and i've
it has haunted me ever since in in in a
way of like
like i'm like i can't he he if he ever
lost a moment's sleep or ever [ __ ]
thought about this beyond the
conversation we had
it was wasted time because nothing but
positive has come from
smoking weed in my life and i think i've
illustrated that
like pretty well but also i could point
to
the fact that like
i don't know like have you ever gotten
in a fight when you've been stoned
no no it's it has a very calming effect
it really does and again i ain't trying
to sell you and [ __ ] but it's like it's
it's not what we were told in the 80s
and it's not oxycontin or [ __ ] heroin
and it's
not even liquor which you know don't get
me started i could [ __ ] do i
i'll become you on the subject of
[ __ ] alcohol and i don't mean owning
a brewery
i don't mean owning a brewery give me
the heart stop yes i'm talking about the
harder lickers
flickers with a queue not made by cube
here's like the weed of water
is the absolute weed of liquors but it
is it's like
you know that's where i go hard and [ __ ]
where i'm like well [ __ ] boobs will
kill a [ __ ] and [ __ ] like that
because it's literal poison
so i could get on a high horse about
that and stuff but
the thought that like that you would
have been troubled in any way shape or
form of like i should have [ __ ] done
something i could have interceded
a would have made for a less happy kevin
smith who might not be alive because i'd
still be smoking cigarettes so i'd
probably die of that [ __ ] widowmaker
and [ __ ]
but also he might be wealthy but you
guys would be [ __ ] broke
because all the jobs came from weed
yeah um i don't know as green as this
wall is
that's as green as your money is my
friend
[Laughter]
um again i think that one at one one day
we'll come to uh have a conversation
where you'll see that
the weed was not his ability to dismiss
the last half hour of you talking is
amazing
[ __ ] last 25 years but regardless
he's absolutely right
we will have a conversation one day i
don't know that i'll be like you're
right
you put too much emphasis and importance
upon weed that and didn't give yourself
enough
credit that you could have done all
those things i'll do you one better than
that
you've take weed out of it i don't give
myself enough credit period like you
know [ __ ] jordan says it all the time
she's just like
um i've met 500 people that made clerks
and none of them are you according to
you because i'm always like without this
[ __ ]
clerks don't happen without this looks
don't happy without this [ __ ]
so i'm always like [ __ ] doing that
kind of [ __ ] but um
i feel like this is how i explained it
to walt and it's an analogy that i've
become very fond of
i could eat spaghetti plain like
spaghetti is edible and physically
satisfying
why would i ever eat spaghetti without
sauce sauce just
improves it doesn't it doesn't mean i
need the sauce to eat the spaghetti but
my god it just makes it better it makes
it
so much vastly better the closing what
was it called again bending time
reference was all about me going like
we're literally sitting around a table
and getting paid money to sit around
talk about comic books that's a [ __ ]
magic trick
and not everyone is ever going to pull
that magic trick off smoking weed was
not like this is the only way the magic
trick works
smoking weed was my way of being like
thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen like that
was a [ __ ] magic trick to pull off so
i enjoyed getting high
before i sat around and talked because
it was like it made a great thing even
better
but also as i pointed out during the
conversation and walter touched on it
i talked about like i could sit there
and [ __ ] soliloquize about batman and
spider-man blah blah blah
and walter's right i could always talk
very passionately about things i was
passionate about however
being that we were new to the tv
business and the game was about content
creating as much content as possible for
them to shave down into shows
being a loquacious stoner helped that
show if i had not been a stoner i'm not
going to say we wouldn't have made it
seven seasons but it would not be the
show it was because i'd be like that's
interesting what about you brian i mean
literally but you realize literally for
the last hour
every single thing you
equate to weed though yes everything it
feels like
yes that's not normal it's not but well
but my whole life's not normal clerks
ain't normal
[ __ ] dogma's not normal the fact that
a kid from highlands became like [ __ ]
internationally known and i get to dress
like a child for my life for my living
but there's thousands and thousands of
kevin smith's out there
in other fields how dare you
i'm telling you how special you are like
you're one of a million buddy
yes there are many of us and guess what
a lot of us are stoners as well
it's i'm not saying it's necessary at
all and i don't say it's the key
but i'm just saying like it really did
allow all of this [ __ ] to happen
it didn't you [ __ ] were you were
stone cold sober when you made clerks
yes
i'm talking about all this [ __ ] like
we're in a room with your green screen
in it
i can draw you in half and i'll do it
for another two hours a direct line from
weed
to this we're talking about your world
yes but clerks happen but again
clerks is a magic trick right and i've
even though i keep spending that
coin that i've you know [ __ ] created
by saying the word i say clerks every
day and a half for like 27 years
clerks ran out of cash a long [ __ ]
time ago
and then i made maul rats and that
[ __ ] died and then chasing amy
brought me back and then dogma
jane sambot shrugged back jersey girl
kills me again
um clerks ii brings me kind of back
zach and miri make a porno doesn't kill
my career but kills me inside where i'm
like this is
i'm [ __ ] i am this guy i'll never be
a patel that was the whole year where i
was like
apatow does what i do and he makes more
money yeah
well then he does it good too and yes no
no good you're not opposite
right that's true but i'm believing i'm
happy to be me but there was a time in
my life before i was a stoner
where i spent a lot of [ __ ] time
thinking about like why
judd apatow and why not me just like in
1995 when mall rats died
i spent an inordinate amount of time
worried about the career of ed burns
i remember that yes he haunted me he was
my [ __ ]
like you know lex luthor and the guy
like he had nothing
didn't say anything about me it wasn't a
personal battle but he had the next
clerks
and that movie made more money brothers
mcmullen and that made 10 million bucks
we made three
and suddenly he was the new golden boy
and [ __ ] and plus he's more attractive
like tom brady good looking
and he also has a wise child he has
uh what is her name christy turlington
yeah
yeah she's she right up there i don't
know my supermodels other than yourself
you're like i know one supermodel and
she belongs to the goat
um yes but wait how did we get on the
[ __ ] supermodels
tom brady no
ed burns like haunted me and was
something that would like
take joy out of my life because i was
like what's he doing
i i spent the first half of my career
looking over the fence
worried that i was going to lose
everything that i have because once you
get something
i had nothing and then i had success and
then you never want to [ __ ] lose
success
and i had the sweetest success which was
like first time out the gate
with an amateurish like spit and blue
effort the world was like you're a
[ __ ] genius and i'm like thank you
and then the next year we're like
ed burns is a genius and i'm like wait
that two of these things can't be true i
saw that [ __ ] movie and [ __ ]
and so suddenly i start judging myself
against others
when i became a stoner i've i've never
judged myself against
anybody else now i'm content to be kevin
smith now i'm content
to be like you guys were like to be like
i know who i
am like and i'm getting a better
understanding of it now you guys know
who you [ __ ] are and stuff
now i'm at a place where like oh i know
who i am i'm mr compassion
um i'm i'm collaboration
i'm mr hope i'm mr you know ben time
cosmic
like those are the things that like are
more important to me now than like
where am i in the directorial period
pyramid i don't even [ __ ] think of
myself as a director anymore and to be
fair most critics don't either
but i spin so many other plates and that
also came from weed
that freedom allowed me to like let go
of movies in a way where i could
interact with them where it wasn't
desperation like
if i didn't have weed and it didn't lead
to everything else and [ __ ] like that
my only source of income would be
[ __ ] movies and so i'd be treating
the thing i love
like an atm like a prostitute and [ __ ]
and i that was the one thing that bugged
me about the movie business in the
beginning i was like i love this [ __ ] so
much but it's like
i literally have to do it now i'm
dependent on it because this is what
pays my rent
becoming a stoner allowed me to be like
movies are just something i also do
but i can make my money standing on a
stage talking now i did go
on stage and talk for long before i was
a stoner we all know
there's a series of videos of me doing
it but i submit to you watch an evening
with kevin smith
and then watch like anything i've done
in the last like 10 [ __ ] years
i'm so luconic and
[ __ ] like i can't be bothered to
answer your question but i'll tell the
superman story one more time
like it's a kid who don't appreciate it
because he's so scared it's all gonna
[ __ ] go away he's also [ __ ] scared
of like are they gonna think i'm a
[ __ ] idiot or something
him going like i don't wanna do comic
book men because what if they make us
look like [ __ ]
was something that i completely
identified with and at a time
would have made me go you're right let's
not [ __ ] do this because the worst
thing that could happen is we might look
like [ __ ]
but being a stoner i was like i don't
care we're gonna have a [ __ ] tv show
we're gonna have a [ __ ] tv show with
my [ __ ] friends we're gonna sit
around we're gonna [ __ ] talk about
comics in my own comic book store is
amazing
so it it only helped one day we may have
a discussion where i'm like oh you're
right i didn't need it
but that would be like saying i didn't
need spaghetti sauce but [ __ ] i loved
it
i'm glad spaghetti sauce existed because
it made spaghetti so much better butter
noodles
that's for other people spaghetti sauce
for me
um that was uh that was
that was the conversation two hours of
the conversation
but um it was and it didn't end with him
going like you're right
i don't want to end that way tonight you
didn't even have to tell us that kev we
knew
as sure as if we were listening to the
conversation that's so true these two
guys were sitting there going you poor
son of a [ __ ]
like i know what actually is like you
only got off with an hour [ __ ]
but it was also like you know one of
those things where i was like oh my god
like
i've known this guy for close to 30
years if not more than this point 30
years and [ __ ]
and like i could count on exactly maybe
two fingers the amount of times we've
ever like
pitched voices and [ __ ] like went at
each other or something like that
and that's where this came from like
came from a place of like i'm so [ __ ]
mad at you i'm going to tell you the
truth
which to me was also like that i was
scared in a minute because i was like
what is the truth
like because i honestly the thing i was
most terrified about i was so relieved
when you were like i should have [ __ ]
stopped you from smoking weed because i
honestly thought you were gonna be like
i never [ __ ] liked you and i think
you're a [ __ ] idiot that would have
[ __ ] destroyed me because i was like
i knew it
i knew it all this time
i got a better time
is that true yeah because that that does
does play into like your your
the feeling of like not knowing because
how could you not know that i would ever
never say that though because i i mean
as much as we're friends
it's not like i see you every day i've
moved away like literally 20 years ago
and if you really trace
our all of this back all the
clerks uh [ __ ] smodcast testy
comic book men not so much impractical
jokes jokers
uh although you know it's in the mix
it's in the mix
i didn't smoke one of those big fat ones
you might be able to come up and be like
i got
ij2
i don't need i don't need [ __ ] smoke
to come up with ij too
that's just me going can we do it again
but with my friends
yeah yeah it is uh yeah no it's
it's it is i imagine yeah there's just
i mean i don't know that's that's that
is troubling though that you would even
i did honestly i was scared about that
because you were so angry and also the
way you were setting it up the senate
was probably the angriest call that
we'll probably ever have in our life
probably all right god i [ __ ] hope so
because i don't know if i can make it
through another one but i'll be honest
with you the first hour was more
harrowing than the second two
the second two made the first hour
palatable because afterwards like for
the first hour i was like my god we're
literally [ __ ] fighting i haven't
i can't remember [ __ ] last time i've
raised my voice with this guy
but when it went into when you got so
mad that you were like [ __ ] you you're
a stoner addict everything got peaceful
because i was like
oh no i'm not like you know he's got me
on the other thing but here
i don't know i don't think i'm that at
all and it became a warmer conversation
to me even though
you know it was filled with me defending
myself and our lives
and all the money we've made in the last
[ __ ] 10 years but it was still
it came from a place of concern like at
the end of the day
like we're all having to laugh and [ __ ]
but it literally did come from a place
of concern you may have been mad at the
moment but [ __ ] you were mad enough
to be like i'm gonna [ __ ] spill a
truth on you and here's my truth
is i'm concerned about you and it could
be paired with judgment
as much as you shouldn't be doing this
or whatever the [ __ ] but it ultimately
at the center
was concerned and that that took a load
off because i swear to god that was one
of the things that went
as you were because you said it twice
and you're like i'm not gonna say you
know what i'm just gonna say no i'm not
gonna say and they're like i'm [ __ ]
saying it and i was like he's
he's that would be that's honestly the
worst thing i could imagine is like our
friendship has been a fraud
like [ __ ] it's all predicated on i
don't [ __ ] know you or something like
that
and i was like i don't think i can
handle that you going like you smoke
weed i'm like oh i can handle this
because i do
and i can talk about it it's great likes
and stuff like that
but the first the first hour was was
tough second
hour two and three was i found
illuminating and honestly i feel one of
the best conversations we've had in
years
because i'm like he doesn't have to
agree with me
but he knows me a little better now as
opposed to a guy from the other side of
the country
going like he's smoking too much weed
and not having a
single [ __ ] perception of other than
seeing there's a bit more weight to why
you're
doing it than other than just like i
can't talk about spider-man unless i'm
high which to be fair
that's not what i said at all i i would
never say that
you know mall rats is proof that that's
[ __ ] not true but i said what
i said it was great that i was a starter
particularly during that because i would
go on
[ __ ] like very grand eloquently to
the point where i looked across the
table and the two of you were like
[ __ ] come on just [ __ ] wrap it up
and we get it
[ __ ] yes wrap it up and [ __ ] so i
know
like uh that that that's what i was
referring to not that like i could never
talk about this [ __ ] until i found weed
um but yes a very
charming moment in our friendship a very
necessary [ __ ] moment and
honestly a necessary conversation not so
much for what was talked about but just
that we talked
that long as well not just like how are
you good how's the store
great what is testy up to this and just
information conveyance
this was the kind of conversation we
used to have remember we sat around
[ __ ] quick stop when
me and him weren't talking at all yeah
walter would come to quick stop like you
know
and at nine o'clock and we'd close at 10
30 and me him and sometimes ed
would be sitting there until two in the
morning either in quick stop or in the
parking lot right outside
with him going you got to call bry you
have to be the one to call brian i was
like [ __ ] he should call me
like he'll never do that he's not that
guy you just you are that guy
and i'm like well i'm weak and he's like
well i'm not weak but like you should
call him you because he's not gonna
[ __ ] call you
and did that for like hours that became
like one of the constant conversations
in the year that brian and i
didn't really speak and stuff um
and then i called brian after i went to
the forum and i was like
hey you got to come to this and brian
went and he was like i ain't doing this
it was like one of the things where like
you graduate you got to invite people
and
and like it's you know not a scam but
it's a pyramid they're like you bring in
[ __ ] more and you bring in more
so i brought him and moser and moser
went and did the forum but brian never
did
i went there and i was like this is
[ __ ] this bullshit's weird
this is like new age [ __ ] that i can't
get very cynical
his reaction would have been the only
reaction that would have been worse or
more implausible would be his if i was
like
let's listen to this lady talk about
she's gonna destroy us in three days and
remake us while he's like
[ __ ] this he didn't ever ask me to go
well you know i mean i'm sure i
i used it to be able to speak to him for
the first time so like that was good
thing
it wasn't so much like i think brian
will love this but it allowed me to call
up brian and be like hey how are you and
i was like oh
how are you and it did brian's infinite
credit
you were right for a year you've been
left just [ __ ] call him
if you just reach out everything will go
back to normal as quickly i
swear to you i was like no no he has to
do the calling and when i did call him
everything did go back to normal as
quickly as possible like [ __ ]
so much so that he was like yeah i'll
take a ride up to this thing with you
and then do you remember driving home
and like there was a prostitute on the
side of the road
talking to her pull over let's talk to
this toothless prostitute
and scott moser had just met brian and
he's just like is he always like this
i'm like yeah that's his thing
he's like hookers i'm like no just
talking to people
poking around and [ __ ] i'm in the middle
of nowhere it was like on the side of a
highway in a park
and you gave her money too and not like
here's money for a blow job you're like
take this money go home stop doing this
he said and [ __ ]
and she had multiple missing teeth and
so even though he kindly gave her money
too he was like kindly suggesting
uh [ __ ] dental work i remember at the
time as well he was like you know you
should really see a dunces but not in a
[ __ ] shitty mocking way
because i remember driving home scott
was just like why did he talk to her
like that and i'm like
he's interested in people he he likes
talking to people
liking talking to people uh is what has
gotten us all
so far all of us spend our lives
spending money
earned from simply talking to people and
that circle has gotten much smaller in
the quasi quasi-case of quinn
he at least talks to total strangers in
the world by virtue of his work he's
forced to talk to strangers yeah yeah
look like an [ __ ] and it [ __ ] pays
um these guys go ahead created your own
world you
literally have your own fiefdom where
you never have to worry
and i don't think you do anymore but
it's probably still built into your dna
you never have to worry about
worried about looking like an [ __ ] or
somebody being like these [ __ ] idiots
and [ __ ]
your audience like would watch you read
the phone book to borrow a
[ __ ] tired old cliche they would well
here your audience would watch you
[ __ ] uh read about the the
violent deaths of their loved ones and
still you'd get a laugh out of them
where they'd be like oh brian you've
done it again
um it is uh it's incredibly unique and
and i'm sure you guys don't spend a lot
of time staring at it and stuff like
that
um because you know you're in the thick
of it but somebody who's an outsider
who's been witness to it the whole time
is nothing but [ __ ] impressive um the
things that you guys have built for
yourselves
uh the things that i built with your
[ __ ] help
and who knows what's [ __ ] next
that's the thing it's like you couldn't
have even seen a green screen wall
25 years ago or [ __ ] 10 years ago
or five years ago and yet here we sit
next to a green screen wall what happens
five years from now
i'm not asking for amy all four walls
are green
that's when we go cosmic
um there it is folks if you've been
listening to this very long ass podcast
you can watch this very long-ass podcast
in one of two places it starts over on
our youtube channel
but the rest of it you gotta watch and
we get into good [ __ ] and whatnot if
you're hearing this
um the rest of it you can watch at uh
tell them steve dave patreon what is it
called
yeah it's patreon.com is that what it is
and ralph's is like
patreon.com the
the ralph report or something like that
um the adjust one more time most of the
audience of course that listens to
[ __ ]
podcasts there's a big crossover with
tessie however there are a bunch of
people that are not so
this is a chance for sale i know well
believe me after all this they've
listened to
enlightened yes they are that's all they
don't know how to bend time you guys are
spending time yeah
they're [ __ ] missing out give me give
them the address again where they can go
at uh patreon.com tell them steve dave
and there's so much good [ __ ] on there
merchandise and videos and podcasts
you're not kidding it ain't just hype he
ain't just saying that in a way of like
oh
[ __ ] come see our [ __ ] like they
literally have a bunch of shank too
right it's like it's
it's not like you only get this month
it's like three years worth of three
years worth of
is that right so if they join now do
they get like an old lamp and [ __ ]
no no the content was new
i was like how many lamps did you make
we got a lot of skulls
that's what we'll say on your grave you
got a lot of skulls not a lot of lamps
300 different [ __ ] pieces of content
yeah yeah yeah
unbelievable man um all from [ __ ]
talk all from just sitting around and
[ __ ] talking all from weed
and weed as well second half came from
weed as we all know
i won't go down the rabbit hole again i
think any of the 300 pieces of content
have any
anybody's uh under the influence are
they i don't know you guys but it was
all born
under the influence it doesn't matter
it's tainted from the start
certainly the audience don't judge them
too hard man
good paying customers what is
tattletails
oh on tattletails and i and explain is
telltale's the game show yeah so what
was the riff
i think well we did a like a take on it
right
right
with a bunch of uh people in our
universe and uh it was get them in his
drinking going on and that on that set
for the very first time ever
and was it in the around the table oh
outside the table outside the set
so it didn't touch the inner sanctum
though oh
maybe it was difficult it was difficult
to deal with
a cosine rated i co-signed with you i
drunks
that's my [ __ ] that's my kryptonite
that's when i lose that's when
when it's your job to dress up like
you're from the 70s and drink like come
on
wait who was the drinker that was frank
five it was all i think everybody was
drinking on it
mary beth was drinking and mary was
drinking yeah
i really i wasn't it rare is the man
who can walk through this life and find
joy
absolutely unassisted happy is the man
who can do that
hats off to you walt flanagan the rest
of us need a lot of spaghetti sauce to
get through
um you have just been listening to me do
one of my favorite things in the world
ladies and gentlemen and the thing that
uh when i [ __ ] leave this world i'll
probably be like god i should have done
that more
but it always makes me happy to know
that they're sitting around and doing it
uh still in my absence and stuff
uh talking uh to you guys thank you
brian thank you brian thank you walter
thank you
thank you for taking the ball and
[ __ ] running with it like
it's a joy to watch testy continue to
[ __ ] grow
um and i look forward to yes seeing the
other three walls become green
that ladies and gentlemen is uh smodcast
for this week man i'm kevin smith
right johnson frank quinn walt flanagan
you go bend time kids have a week
you